شكرا للزميل محمد الطميحي اهلا بكم
مشاهدينا اذا تستمر معكم العربيه في
تغطيتها الحيه والمباشره للاحداث في
السودان اذا في اليوم الثامن من
الاشتباكات تتواصل المواجهات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في مناطق متفرقه من
العاصمه الخرطوم في اليوم الثامن ايضا
الجميع يريد ان يغادر معظم دول العالم
تريد ان تخرج دبلوماسييها في اسرع وقت
ممكن فالوضع اصبح غير امن على الاطلاق
الامم المتحده وسبع دول على الاقل تسعى
لاجلاء رعاياها بشكل عاجل
[موسيقى]
في هذا السياق اعلن الجيش السوداني ان
عمليه اجلاء رعايه كل من الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وفرنسا والصين ستتم خلال ساعات
بواسطه طائرات عسكريه اضاف الجيش السوداني
ان هذه الخطوه تاتي بعد استجابه القائد
الاعلى للجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
لطلبات رؤساء عدد من الدول الذين اجروا
اتصالات معهم
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه عن
بدء ترتيب باجلاء المواطنين السعوديين
ورعايا عدد من الدول
من السودان الى السعوديه وذلك وفق ما
نقلته وكاله واس
الى ذلك او عز الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي
بارسال وحده بحريه الى شواطئ السودان
لحمايه المواطنين الكوريين الجنوبيين وقال
المتحدث الرئاسي ان الرئيس او عزا بنشر
وحده تشونغهاي لمكافحه القرصنه بشكل فوري
عند شواطئ السودان لحمايه المواطنين
الكوريين الجنوبيين وارسال طائره عسكريه
الى القاعده الامريكيه في جيبوتي للتحضير
لاجلاء رعايه كوريا الجنوبيه من السودان
بسبب الاشتباكات المسلحه بين قوات الدعم
السريع
والجيش السوداني
ومع دخول الاشتباكات في السودان اسبوعها
الثاني اجر رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه
الامريكيه مارك ميل اتصالا هاتفيا مع رئيس
القوات المسلحه السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان واوضح المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه جوزيف هولسد ان الطرفين ناقش
سلامه المواطنين الامريكيين
وتطورات الاوضاع وما يحدث في السودان
تجري الدول الاعضاء الخمسه في مجلس الامن
مناقشات حول احتمال عقد جلسه مفتوحه بمجلس
الامن الدولي عن السودان الاحد او الاثنين
قالت بعثه السودان في الامم المتحده
للعربيه ان الجلسه المقرره سيتم عقدها وفق
قواعد الاجراءات الدوليه ولا يمكن منع عقد
الاجتماع طالما تم طلب ذلك من اعضاء
المجلس واضافت بعثه السودان انه يجب ان
تكون نتائج الاجتماع مرضيه وليست مجرد
ظهور اعلامي
[موسيقى]
اذا وهذه صور مباشره الان مشاهدين لتصاعد
اعمده الدخان امامنا من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم واندلاع حريق ضخم داخل مطار
الخرطوم الدولي كما نشاهد الان امامنا على
الشاشه طبعا كنا قد تابعنا خلال الساعات
الماضيه ذوي انفجارات ايضا وسمع لذوي
اطلاق النار بالقرب من محيط القياده
العملي القوات المسلحه في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم لا تزال اعمده والسنه
[موسيقى]
اللهب اذا تتصاعد من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم هذه صور مباشره خاصه للعربيه من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم كما ذكرنا
واياكم قبل قليل بان هذه الاشتباكات
العنيفه لا تزال متواصله اليوم الثاني على
التوالي بعد ان
بعد ان نشب هذا الخلاف والصراع والاحتراب
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
اذا هذه صور لاندلاع حريق ضخم داخل مطار
الخرطوم
الدولي
ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
مرحبا بك معنا على شاشه العربيه شكرا
اختيارك العربيه للظهور عليها الجيش اعلن
انكم تلقيتم عدد من الاتصالات من عدد من
رؤساء الدول فيما يتعلق باجلاء رعاياها من
السودان ما الذي دار بينك وبينهم وتم
التنسيق والترتيب عليه سياده الفريق
مرحبا وعليكم السلام طبعا
قالت هذه الدول قلقونا من مالات الاحداث
الجاريه الان في السودان وايضا نحن
نشاطرهم هذا القلق لان
الاوضاعيه والاوضاع المعيشيه وصحيه كلها
في تدهور يومي مستمر
والجميع يحس كما ايضا نحن نحس على ضروره
ايقاف هذه الحرب وهم طلبوا تسجيل
اخلاء رعاياهم ووعدناهم بالقيام بالضروريه
لتامين وخروج رعاياهم خروج امن ما هي هذه
الاجراءات التي ستقومون بها سياده الفريق
كيف ستضمنون سلامه اجلام مواطني ورعاي هذه
الدول من السودان
نحن نغفر المطارات اللازمه ونفصل الممرات
الامنه في بعض المناطق التي
بها بعض الاشكالات الامنيه هل كل المطارات
تحت سيطره الجيش
كل المطارات تحته الجيش مطار الخرطوم في
اشكاليه ومطار نياله اشكاليه بقيه بطارات
السودان كلها تحت سيطره الدوله وبالتالي
مطار الخرطوم لن يتم من اجلاء مواطني اي
دول او رعايه بسبب حده الاشتباكات حول
المطار سيئه الفريق
بالتاكيد نعم
يعني هناك من ينظر بان مساله اجراء اجلاء
الرعايه من السودان هي تنذر بتصعيد كبير
سيكون خلال الايام القادمه هل هذا حقيقي
طبعا رعايه الدول اصابهم الفلا واصابهم
الخوف من الممارسات مجموعات الدعم السريعه
المنفرده داخل الاحياء السكنيه وهي تفتش
المنازل وتصادر الاموال وتعتدي على
الدبلوماسيه دون اي مراعاه لحرمه هذه
البعثات وللقوانين بها حتى دون اي مراعاه
لحرمه المواطنين
هذه المجموعات منتشره داخل احياء السكنيه
داخل المجمعات الخدميه وتقوم
بافعاله الخ
وض يعني سياده الفريق هذا الانتشار لهذه
القوات قوات الدعم السريع في الاحياء
السكنيه في الخرطوم يعني بانكم لم تسيطروا
بشكل كامل على العاصمه الخرطوم حتى الان
نعم بمجموعات كثيره جدا من هذه القوات وسط
الاحياء السكنيه لتفادي ضربات المدفعيه
ضربات الطيران نحن لا نريد ان نقدم على
مثل هذه الخطوات حتى لا
الضرر وسط السكان او وسط المجمعات السكنيه
ونحن نطالب ايضا اذا كانت هنالك فعلا
قواعد معروفه للحرب يجب ان لا تتم لا يتم
استخدام المواطنين كدلوع البشريه يجب ان
نجد هذا السلوك ادانا من من الجميع هل تم
فعلا استخدام المدنيين كدروع بشريه في
المواجهات بينكم وبين قوات الدعم السريع
بالتاكيد الان مجموعات كبيره اخرجت
المواطنين في المنازل اخرجت
اخذت المستشفيات واحتلت المستشفيات
مدير من كل الان قواتهم داخل الخرطوم في
مناطق سكنيه وسط السكان والصلاحيات
السكنيه يعني هناك نزوح كبير للمدنيين من
العاصمه
الخرطوم يعني السؤال عن من يسيطر على
المفاصل المهمه في العاصمه اليوم هناك
تضارب للامباء بانكم سيطرتم مثلا على محيط
قياده القوات العامه المسلحه على المطار
على عدد من المناطق الحيويه داخل
الخرطوم حقيقه السيطره اليوم في العاصمه
الخرطوم كيف يمكن ان تتحدث عنها احنا كنا
موجودين في مقراتنا وتم الهجوم علينا من
قبل هذه المجموعات المتمرده طبعا
نحن نقوم بالدفاع ولا نريد ان نخرج نخرج
الى خارج دائره الدفاع لاننا نظن ان ذلك
يتسبب في اضرار كبيره واضرار بالغه على
السودانيين الان
تشردت مئات قتلوا
البنيه التحتيه يتضررت في حرب عبسيه ليس
لديها جدوى سوى اكاذيب الذي يدعيها الطرف
الاخر لانه يحارب الشلول ويحارب الجماعات
الاسلاميه الان ما في اي جماعات اسلاميه
اصابت والذي يكون ضرر وان مضطر اصابه
السودانيين واصاب مخدرات الدوله واثار
القوات النظاميه واصعب اس الدوله
السودانيه في
اجتماعي في قوميتها في وحدتها لذلك هذه
الادعات اش كاذبه التي تسار بان الحرب ضد
الجماعات الاسلاميه هذه اكذوبه يراد بها
استعطاف بعض المجموعات التي تنافس هؤلاء
الجماعات العداء نحن نؤكد ان الجيش هو جيش
سوداني خالص وليس جيش من برهان ودليل انه
بره يخرطوم الان في الولايات السودان
هنالك سيطره للقوات المسلحه على كل
الولايات او على كل القياسات الاقاليد هذا
يدلل عن القوات المسلحه قوات قوميه قوات
معركتها هي ضد
الهيمنه التي يدعى اليها بعض الاشخاص او
بعض المجموعات التي تريد ان تستحوذ على
الدوله السودانيه فيما يخصكم سياده الفريق
يعني هناك انباء تحدثت بانكم يعني خرجتم
من العاصمه الخرطوم بسبب يعني
الاشتباكات القريبه من محيط القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه القوات الدعم
السريعه نشرت عدد من الفيديوهات قالت
بانها اقتحمت مقر
اقامتك شخصيا هل تستطيع الرد عليها واين
كنت اصلا منذ بدايه هذه الاشتباكات وحتى
اليوم
هذه هي مهمتي وهذا شرفي لن اخرج الا
محمولا على نعش لكن انا موجود
وواج الدستوري ودافع عن الدوله السودانيه
ولا ادافع عن شخص ولا ادافع عن جهه ولا
دافع عن كيان انا ادافع عن السودان ادافع
عن وحدته ودافع عن
بقاء جميعا انا موجود صحيح المنزل تم
التسلل نصوص
داخل المنزل من بعض المنزل هو في طرف ليس
داخل القياده بالمعنى انه تسلل لبعض
النصوص وعاصوا فيه فتاه
السؤال المهم اليوم سياده الفريق الى اي
مدى زمني ممكن ان تستمر هذه الحرب هل
لديكم يعني موعد محدد او لديكم استراتيجيه
عسكريه تبنون من خلالها وقتا زمنيا او
توقعا لنهايه هذه ال ال الحرب
لم تعلم الى اي مدى ستنتهي هذه الحرب وكيف
واين هذه
بدنيات معروفه في الحروب ما في جهه تعرف
ان الحرب
طبيعه السودان طبيعه السودانيين طبيعه
العمليات الجاريه داخل المدن تحتاج الى
جهود كبيره تحتاج الى صبر تحتاج الى طول
نفس كلنا نعلم ان الحرف داخل المناطق
المبنيه ليست كالحرب في المناطق المكشوفه
او مناطق اخرى التوقيتات الزمنيه هنا غير
وارد الناس متاكد من ان الله بعد اسبوع
بعد 10 يوم لكن نحن نناشد بان يجب ان
تتوقف هذه الحرب يجب ان نخرج كل المسلحين
من داخل الاحياء السكنيه يجب ان نخرج كل
المسلحين من المنشات الخدميه
في الاقسام الشرطيه المحتله المستشفيات
المحتله المرافق الحيويه كلها محتله ولا
احد يستطيع ان يقدم خدمه للمواطنين السجون
تم اقتحامه واطلق سراح كل المجرمين هنالك
جزر الفوضى شامله قد تعمر سوداني اذا لم
ننتبه جيدا ونوقف جميع هذه الحرب اللعينه
الفوضى الشامله ما الذي تقصد يعني بهذه
الكلمه هناك مجموعه الازمات الدوليه كانت
قد حذرت من ان السودان قد ينزلق الى حرب
اهليه بسبب هذه الاشتباكات وبسبب ما يحدث
اليوم في السودان هل تعتقدون بان هذا
سيناريو مرجح سياده الفريق
بالامس اقتحمت مجموعه من الدعم السريع
سيدنا الهدى وهو اكبر سجن في العاصمه به
رابطه 8000 وثم قتل الحراس والضباط واطلاق
صلاح جميع هؤلاء السجناء اتيهم المجرمين
المخدرات يوم القتله اليوم ايضا سيدنا
نزابي ام درمان به الاف برضه من السجينات
الان ايضا اقتحمته هذه القوات واطلق
الصباح كلها هؤلاء المجنونين جهه تقوم مثل
هذه الاعمال وتستحل اقسام الشرطه من عداوه
معنى ذلك ان هذه الجهه تريد ان تشير
الفوضى في الدوله طيب اسالك عن قائد الدعم
السريع مباشره محمد حمدان
اعتبر انك غدرت به وصفك ايضا حتى باوصاف
اخرى منها انك انقلبت على السودان وبانه
يجب ايضا كذلك تسليمك للعداله كيف تعلق
على كل ما وصفك به سياده الفريق
انا اقول رمتني
كيف اكثر من ذلك
طيب اتهم ايضا حتى فلول النظام السابق
بانهم يحيطون بك بانهم هما هما
لمهاجمه قوات الدعم السريع
وهو يعلم تماما انني ليست لدي اي علاقه
بالنظام السابق ولا جميع يعلم ذلك نحن
قوات مسلحه نعمل احترافيه وواجبنا حمايه
السودان حتى
معظم هذه الاشاعه يعلم المصداقيه ويعلم
انه انها كلمه حق اريد بها باطل او كلمه
باطل اريد فيها ما هو مصير دقله بالنسبه
لكم في الجيش سياده الفريق
واصلا
مصيره مرتبط
اذا كانت هنالك استجابه
للجنوح للسلم
هل هو على قائمه المستهدفين بالنسبه لكم
خلال المعارك
نحن لا نفتح اي شخصيات رسميه كما هم
يفعلون ذلك هم الان يستهدفون القيادات
للقوات المسلحه ويرسلون اتياما القناصه
لتقتلهم نحن لدينا نظم واعراف
ونحترم العادات التقاليد العسكريه ونعرف
كيف سيكون القتال لا نستهدف شخصيات اذا
نحتف اشخاص نحن نستهدف مهددات الامن
الوطني نستحديث العمل الذي يغدر بامن
الدوله هل تعلمون الان اين هو حميتي او
لديكم معلومات سياده الفريق
اتهمتم عدد من الدول الاقليميه بانها
تساند الدعم السريع تساند مباشره محمد
حمدانو هل يمكن ان تكشف لنا عن هذه الجهات
سيتم فريق
هنالك معلومات وردت لان هنالك محاولات هذه
المعلومات في مثل هذه الظروف تكون متواتره
من جهات مختلفه لديها مصلحه
وكان هنالك
[موسيقى]
حتى اتصل به شخصيا هو واكد بان هذه
المزاعم مداعم يراد بها الفتنه والوقيعه
بين الجيران
هناك معلومات اجنبيه سربت عبر الصحافه يوم
امس وايضا حتى خلال
الايام الماضيه منذ بدايه الاشتباكات بان
الدعم السريع الدعم السريع عفوا تلقى دعم
باسلحه من قوات فاجنر ما هي دقه هذه
المعلومات اولا بالنسبه لكم سياده الفريق
نحن نتحرر من دقه هذه المعلومات حتى الان
هل انتم يعني
مستعدون
للتراجع عن دعم
عن دمج الدعم السريع مع الجيش كحل للازمه
سياده الفريق هل هذا مطروح على الطاوله
نحن نعلم ان دوله بها جيشين فيكون مصيره
مصيره ما يحدث الان لذلك يصير
ان يكون جزء من
هل هناك اي خلاف بينكم وبين الروس سيد عبد
الفتاح العلاقه كيف يمكن وصفها يعني بعد
الاتهامات بان فاجنر تساند قوات الدعم
السريع اليوم في السودان تقاتل او ايضا
حتى تمدها باسلحه
متوازنه مع معظم الدول لدينا علاقات مميزه
وجيزه مع روسيا مع امريكا مع كل الفاعلين
في المجتمع الدولي يحتفظ بعلاقات متوازنه
معهم بالنسبه للدول الحدوديه معكم
هل هناك اي خشيه من ان تنزلق في هذا
الصراع من ان ايضا تتدخل في السودان
اتحدثون عن اثيوبيا اتحدث عن تشاد ايضا
كذلك
علاقتنا مميزه وانا على تواصل مع الرئيس
الاثيوبي ونتشاور في كل امر هم البلدين
الاخوه في تشاد ايضا لدينا معاهم تواصل
يوميا مستمر وهم الحدود الان يمكن المئات
القاريين من الدعم السريع تم التحفظ عليهم
للحدود مع مع تشاد
وايضا مئات السيارات
ايضا تم التحفظ عليها بواسطه القوات
المشتركه مع تشاد يعني انتم الان تنفون كل
الانباء التي تحدثت على ان هناك انباء
عن ان هناك توترات على الحدود بينكم وبين
تشاد مثلا
ابدا نحن نعمل في تنسيق جيد ومستمر ويوميا
نتبادل المعلومات ونتبادل التواصل مع
الرئيس محمد دبي هم الان على الحدود
موجودين
تحفظون على كل شرط
من الدعم السريع يحاول الدخول الى تشاد
الولايات المتحده هددت بوضعك شخصيا وحميه
ايضا على قائمه العقوبات ان استمرت هذه
الحرب كيف تعلقون سياده الفريق
من اي جهه انا اقوم بواجبي ومستعد لتحمل
اي مسؤوليه تنتج عن ادائي لمهمتي
فيما يخص الهدى سيات الفريق اكثر من خمس
او ست هدى اعلنت في السودان منذ بدايه هذه
الازمه لم يلتزم اي طرف بهذه الهدن الهدن
وتم اختراقها من تحملون المسؤوليه هل انتم
جزء من هذه
هل انتم جزء من مساله اختراق الهدن
الانسانيه في السودان
اي هدنه اعلنت اصلا ما في هدنه حتى ابتدعت
لان
القوات الطرف الاخر غير تسيطر عليها وهي
منتشره في مناطق مختلفه من الحياه السكنيه
وكل يعمل بمفرده كثير من المحرك التجاريه
تم الايداع عليها البنوك
المؤسسات الدوله هؤلاء الاشخاص لعملهم انه
ينهبوا المواطنين الحكوميين حتى البنوك
لذلك هنالك في كل حركه يستخدمون الاسلحه
يستخدمون القوه تضطر القوات المسلحه لان
ترد عليه هل انتم جاهزون لاي هدى انسانيه
ترعاها الامم المتحده او دول ايضا اقليميه
نحن
ابناء الوطن نزع الى المحافظه على مكتسبات
الدوله السودانيه نزل على المحافظه على
نسيج الاجتماعي والوحده الوطنيه كل اجراء
يساعد على هذه الامور نحن سنمضي فيه ليس
لدينا مصلحه يعني يموت او يموت السودانيين
او تدمر البنيه التحتيه للدوله بالنسبه
للعمليه السياسيه سياده الفريق في السودان
ما هو مصيرها الان
نحن ملتزمين باكمال العمليه السياسيه
ومتزمين وهذا واجب حتى ننهي الصراع لان
هذا الصراع هو في الاساس جزء منه صراع
سياسي نحن نريد ان ننهي هذه المساله ونحن
مقتنعين بان الحكم العسكري ليس لديه
مستقبل في تطوير اي دوله في العالم لذلك
حريصين وان تكون في حكومه مدنيه اتولى
الشان حكومه مدنيه متوازنه ليس صراعات لا
تجر البلد الى صراع جديد يعني في ظل كل
المطالبات بالتهدئه الوساطات الدوليه ايضا
والاممي التي اعلنت خلال الفترات الماضيه
الدعوات اليكم انتم شخصيا والى قوات الدعم
السريع هل يمكن ان يعود الوضع بينكم وبين
قوات الدعم السريع الى ما كان عليه قبل
هذه الحرب
طبعا لا يمكن ان يعود الى مكان عليه قبل
هذه الحرب لظروف الحاليه التي نعيشها الان
طيب طالما انتم كلكم
كقيادات
داخل القياده العامه الا تخشون من
الاستهداف
نقدم انفسنا لهذا الاستهداف هذا وجدنا ولا
يضيء اذا كان قتلنا في سبيل ونحن مقتنعين
بان ما نبدي واجبنا ولنذهب لهذا الوعي
طيب اخيرا ما هي رسالتك الى
شقيقه ايضا
انا الجميع خاسر فيها والخاسر الاول هو
الشعب السوداني والخاسر الاكبر هو الدوله
السودانيه لذلك يجب ان تتوقف هذه الحرب
يجب ان يعود المقاتلين الى اماكنهم يجب ان
نجلس جميعا سودانيين ونجد المخرج الملائم
حتى نعيد الامل ونعيد الحياه الى من
ينظرون الينا الان
برافو وبحزن وبشفقه
رسالتكم ايضا كذلك الى الشعب السوداني
سياده الفريق
نحن نقول لشعب السوداني ان هذه الحرب فرضت
على القوات المسلحه وفرضت على الشعب
السوداني ايضا كظهير للقوات المسلحه ويجب
ان تنتهي ولما تتوقف نحن نعلم المعاناه
الكبيره جدا التي يعانيها الان مواطنين
وشعبنا لذلك نقول لهم قليل من الصبر وقليل
من الجود وربما ناتي بنتائج ايجابيه تخدم
مستقبل السودان وتخدم مستقبل الدوله
السوداني قبل ان اختم معك اذا سمحت لسياده
الفريق يعني بعد ان يتم اجراء كل الرعايه
ومواطني الدول الاجنبيه من داخل السودان
هناك من يتخوف من ان ينزلق الوضع في
السودان الى ما هو اسوا هل هذا السيناريو
موجود لديكم
يعني سبل للتعامل معه او انه مطروح كذلك
لديكم
نحن كما ذكرته لك في البدايه ان كل ما
نبدا الحرب لا اعلم نكاحيه ولا اعلم من
حيث مهما كانت توقعاته وما كانت حساباته
لذلك السودان مليء
بالوطنين
بالمخلصين ليبي من يتحدث بصوت العقل ونحن
نرجو ان تدخل العقال
والذين مصلحه البلاد لمنع انزلاق البلاد
الى الفوضى الشامله اشكرك جزيل الشكر انضم
الينا عبر الهاتف رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا جزيلا
على الارض رصدت كاميرا العربيه لحظه قصف
بالقرب من جسر المسلميه في الخرطوم حيث تم
سماع صوت انفجار تلاه تصاعد كثيف للادخنه
نشاهد
للعربيه ان سته اشخاص من عائله واحده
قتلوا واصيب شخص اخر بجروح خطيره بعد سقوط
قذائف مدفعيه على حي المنصوره السكني في
ام درمان
ضربت الجماعه
البيوت قدام بيوت
وانا ما مرضت في الشارع قالوا لي اياها في
اولاد
ومعي هنا في الاستوديو مديره مكتب العربيه
في الخرطوم لينا يعقوب لينا مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه سمعتي قبل
قليل
لهذه التصريحات
للسيد البرهان كيف تعلقين عليها اولا
نعمل الجيد جدا ان يتحدث القاعده العامه
للجيش السوداني
للسودانيين ويطمئنهم ربما بتطورات الاوضاع
العسكريه على الاقل الان خاصه ان
الاشتباكات لم تهدا رغم ان الجانبين في
اوقات سابقه عبر بيانات رسميه تحدثان
الانتصار على وشك والان اشار بصوره واضحه
الى ان قرار الحرب لم يختاروه ونهايه
الحرب لا يعلمون متى بالضبط الان يعني
ستنتهي هناك افادات جديده ربما تقال لاول
مره من القاعده العامه للجيش السوداني
خاصه فيما يتعلق بالاحداث التي جرت امس
باقتحام سجن الهدى رغم ان الدعم السريع
نفى هذا الامر ولكن نحن تواصلنا مع بعض
المساجين الذين كانوا في سجن الهدى من
بينهم كانوا بعض المساجين الذين تم الحكم
عليهم بضع ببضعه سنوات فخرجوا وتحدثوا حتى
الى بعض العاملين في مكتب العربيه في
الخرطوم واكدوا انهم الان يقلقون على
انفسهم وعلى مصيرهم تحدثوا ان هناك قوات
ترتدي زي الدعم السريع جاءت الى السجن
وقامت بفتح الابواب وانهم خرجوا اليوم
القياده العام للجيش السوداني يتحدث ايضا
انه قتلوا بعض افراد الشرطه وبعض الحراس
في هذا السجن هذا يعني ان هناك فوضى كثيره
قد تحدث لان هؤلاء مجرمين محكوم عليهم
بسنوات سجن هذا يعني اختلاط هؤلاء
المجرمين وسط الشارع السوداني وسط
المواطنين كل هذه الامور تثير تشير بصوره
واضحه الى ان عنف ما قد يحدث ايضا وليس
اشتباكات فقط بين الجيش والدعم السريع
يعني هناك جرائم اخرى قد اجشتها السودان
وتشهدها العاصمه الخرطوم خلال الايام
الهدى تحديدا اعتقد ان سجن كوبر فيه حراسه
اكبر واقوى وان يتمكن الدعم السريع من
الذهاب الى سجن الهدى فهو ربما
رشا رساله واشاره ايضا هذا السجن فيه
المجرمين ربما في كوبر هناك شخصيات سياسيه
اي ان الاحكام السياسيه اكثر من كونهم
مجرمين بتهم قتل او السرقات او غيرها لذلك
اطلاق صراحه دعم السريع لهؤلاء المساجين
رغم نفي الدعم السريع فيه اشاره كبيره الى
فوضى جديده وبشكل مختلف في الايام الماضيه
نحن نتحدث عن ازمات انسانيه عن كوارث في
المجال الصحي طبعا نحن نعلم ان المجال
التعليمي توقف طبعا في السودان مع هذه
الحرب هناك شحف في الامداد الغذائي هناك
نقص كبير في الامداد المائي والكهربائي
لكثير من مناطق الخرطوم ولكن ان تضاف الى
هذه الازمات اشياء اخرى جديده هذا يشير
الى فوضى جديده في المشهد السياسي
والعسكري السوداني الان العمليه السياسيه
لم يغفلها السيد البرهان قبل قليل في
اجابته يعني على مصيرها وقال بانهم
متمسكون بهذه العمليه
السياسيه بالنسبه للاحزاب المدنيه اليوم
في السودان كيف يمكن ان تتعاطى مع هذا
التصريح في
الحقيقه الفريق البرهان بان العمليه
السياسيه مستمره هي العمليه السياسيه كانت
مستمره باحزاب معينه بالجيش والدعم السريع
لا اعتقد يعني ان شكل العمليه السياسيه
كما كان قبل هذه الحرب سيستمر بذات الشكل
هو لم يعطي تفاصيل واعتقد انه من المبكر
الان الحديث حول عمليه سياسيه الحديث لابد
ان يدور على وقف هذه الحرب وكيف يمكن
اعاده ما تم تدميره في هذه الحرب هناك
الكثير من المقر الحكوميه المطار المؤسسات
الرسميه البنوك هي الان شبهي مدمره او
معطله هناك كثير من المستشفيات التي لا
تعمل اعتقد ان الحديث عن العمليه السياسيه
قد يكون مبكر لاوانه الان رغم ما تعتبره
القوى السياسيه انها قد تكون محاوله جديده
لتمديد امد الفتره الانتقاليه بالنسبه
للسلطه العسكريه ولكن بعد ان تنتهي هذه
الحرب بلا شك ان هناك كثير من الجهات
والاطراف سواء كانت سياسيه او حتى جهات
دوليه مثل الاليه الثلاثيه او اللجنه
الرباعيه او غيرها قد يضعون شكلا جديدا
لهذا المشهد تحدث ايضا كذلك فيما يخص
المشهد العسكري داخل السودان خصوصا داخل
الخرطوم قال بان هناك مجموعات منتشره داخل
الاحياء السكنيه اكد ايضا كذلك في هذه
المقابله بان فلول القوات الدعم السريعه
لا تزال موجوده في عدد من الاحياء وعدد من
المناطق لم يتم احكام السيطره تماما على
العاصمه
الخرطوم ما الذي يؤشر اليه هذا الامر هو
ليس تحاملا طبعا على الدعم السريع ولكن
هذه افادات لشهود عيان موجودين في الخرطوم
انا اعرف كثير من الصحفيين هناك قوات من
الدعم السريع جاءت ومكثت في منازلهم اخلوا
المنازل خاصه وسط الخرطوم لا اعلم او لم
انتبه ان كان القائد العام للجيش تحدث عن
وجود الدعم السريع وسط الخرطوم بيانات
الجيش تتحدث عن دحر هذه القوات ولكن وسط
الخرطوم غير امن حتى اللحظه هذه المشاهد
التي كنا ننقلها اليوم وفيها بعض المكاتب
الاعلاميه كانت تحيط بها قوات الدعم
السريع وهذه المناطق تشهد اشتباكات بين
الجيش والدعم موجوده في عدد من الاحياء
السكنيه
وقال ايضا بانها تتخذ يعني من بعض
المستشفيات مرتكزات ايضا
عسكريه وذكر بالاضافه اليها بانها تستخدم
المدنيين كدروع بشريه ايضا هذا ما قاله
نعم الفريق البرهان انا متاكده من الجانب
المتعلق بانهم يقتحمون المنازل بانهم
دخلوا المستشفيات لست متاكده من بقيه
الافادات لان هذه الافادات ادلى بها
مواطنون
وصحفيون وكثير من شهود عيان اذا هذه هذه
الاحاديث الصحيحه ولكننا نتحدث انه في وسط
الخرطوم ليس المكان ليس امن بعد اتحدث
بالتحديد عن الاماكن التي تتواجد فيها
كاتب اعلاميه ومكاتب لقنوات واشتباكات
تحدث بالتحديد في موقف شروني بالقرب من
شارع القصر بالقرب من هذا المحيط في في
نمره اثنين هذه مناطق في وسط الخرطوم ما
زالت قوات الدعم السريع تتواجد فيها بعيدا
طبعا قوات الدعم السريع فيها يعني بانها
مناطق غير امنه يعني بانها يعني هذه
المناطق يتم الاعتداد فيها على اي مدنيين
يمرون في هذه الشوارع مباشره
يعني لا استطيع الجزم بانهم يعتدون على اي
مواطن طبعا يعني هذه معلومه لا استطيع
الادلاء بها ولكن ما اعلمه حسب شهود
العيان يعني حسب شهود
الان في حسب شهود عيان خرجوا واخلوا هذه
المنازل بان قوات الدعم السريعه الان
موجوده فيها ايضا موجوده في عدد من
الفنادق يعني نحن بقرب مكتبنا يوجد فندق
كنا نرغب بان ننقل اليه بعض الموظفين هذا
الفندق الان يتواجد فيه الدعم السريع فهذا
يعني ان هناك كثير من المنازل سكانها
ذهبوا منها وجاءت دعم السريع وبقي في هذه
المنازل اما انهم يعتدون على الافراد ربما
يشتبهون في بعض الافراد المارين يقومون
بالاعتداء عليهم ربما في اوقات يقومون
باستفسارهم دون الاعتداء لا اعلم بالضبط
طبيعه ما يحدث يعني ولكن هناك خطوره
حقيقيه لهذه الاشتباكات التي تحدث هو ايضا
القاعده العامه للجيش السوداني تحدث انهم
يتواجدون داخل الاحياء هناك بعض شهود
العيان تحدثوا بان بان قوات الدعم السريع
يعني كانوا يرتدون بعض الزي المدني
باسلحتهم في واحده من الاحياء ان يكون هذا
الموضوع ايضا منتشر يحتاج ايضا لمزيد من
الدقه طيب فيما يخص الاوضاع الصحيه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تحديدا كيف
يمكن الحديث عن وضع المستشفيات هناك عن
الكادر الصحي عن توفر حتى
الادويه للمصابين وحتى للمرضى العاديين
تاتي من العاملين في القطاع الصحي من
بينهم وزير الصحه ووزاره الصحه الاتحاديه
التي تحاول ايضا طمانه المواطنين بان
مستشفيات كانت خارج الخدمه الان هي تعمل
في الحقيقه ارى تحسن فيما يتعلق
بالمستشفيات يوما بعد اخر مقارنه مثالث
يوم اليوم نحن في اليوم الثامن تقريبا
فهناك تحسن على الاقل فيما في فتح بعض
المستشفيات في ان هناك كانت تكدس في البدء
الان اصبحت تستوعب هذه المستشفيات مرضى
بطاقه استيعابيه ليست يعني قليله الامر
الاخر هناك نقص في المستلزمات الطبيه طبعا
معظم نايف الشركات التي تعمل في هذا
المجال هي اما انها تتواجد في مناطق بعيده
عن وسط الخرطوم او انها في وسط الخرطوم
وفي كلا الحالتين من الصعب ان تتحرك وان
تقوم بمد المستلزمات اللازمه سواء كان
للمستشفيات او حتى يعني امس كان بعض
المحاله التجاريه لا يوجد فيها مياه وتحدث
زميلي عطاف محمد مختار قبل يومين بانهم
افطروا على بيبسي لان المياه لم تعد
موجوده هذا يعني انه شح المياه جعل هناك
ازدحام اكبر على المحل التجاريه لشراء كل
المياه الموجوده ففرغت بالتالي هناك نقص
في الامداد سواء كان
حتى في السودان هذا ما قراته على وسائل
التواصل يعني
هل هذه دقيق المعلومه او لا طبعا هي اكيد
دقيقه هذه المعلومه لانها لما تعاني من
شحف المياه والمياه الصالحه للشرب تلجا
الى مياه تباع بقيمه اعلى من الصحي معاليه
جدا وفي كل حرب وفي كل مكان ليس السودان
فقط طبعا يظهر تجار للازمات وهذا ما يحدث
الان في السودان يعني المياه تباع باسعار
غاليه جدا يعني
للاستخدام للغسيل لغيرها احتياجات المياه
كثيره في المنازل السوداني فبلا شك انها
لن تكون صالحه للشرب بذات القدره التي
تكون فيه المياه الصحيه متواجده في
المحاله اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل لان يعقوب مديره مكتب
العربيه انضمت الينا هنا في الاستوديو اذا
مشاهدينا اظهرت مقاطع فيديو متداوله اشعال
النيران وتصاعد اعمده الدخان في مبنى بنك
الجزيره في الخرطوم
المشكله يا صادق يقوم يقع في الكهرباء دي
على الهيكل بيكون قاعد
الطبيه في السودان على الدين عوض من ان
المستشفيات تعاني نقصا حادا في المستلزمات
الطبيه التي يحتاجها الاطباء في العمليات
الجراحيه التي تستطيع الحكومه توفيرها
بسبب المعارك الدائره في انحاء البلاد
الجراحيه هي الاكثر حول جناحه وفي
مستشفيات حاليا يعني فيها نقص كبير جدا في
المعدات الجراحيه مثل الخيوط الشاشه
الطبيه
حتى
الفارغه والمحاليل الوريديه الاتصال من
اول يوم بدات الاجسام الطبيه في مقدمتها
اللجنه التنفيذيه بالاتصال بكل المنظمات
العامله هنا طبيعيه والمنظمات الدوليه
ولكن نظرا لاستمرار القصف هم لديهم
المخازون في في مخازنهم ولكن لا يستطيعون
ضمان
قال مصطفى ادم احمد مدير منظمه الزرقاء
لتنميه ان عمليه جمع الجثث المتناثره في
شوارع الخرطوم باتت تشكل عمليه معقده
لسيما المساحه الواسعه التي تنتشر فيها
وتحللها ما يشكل خطرا على الوضع الصحي
والبيئي في المدينه
حمو زياده سيد حمور مرحبا بك معي على شاشه
العربيه دعنا نبدا في البدايه من
الاحاديث والتصريحات
لسياده الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
قائد الجيش السوداني كيف تعلق عليها
اعتقد ان هذه التصريحات مربكه ومغلقه في
ذات الوقت يعني الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
البرهان حث على وقف الحرب
واعتبر انها حرب عبثيه بينما يعني هو احد
طرفي هذه الحرب فمن يجب عليه ايقافها ان
لم يكن هو والفريق اول محمد حمدان دقلو
ونعيبه في مجلس السياده سياده الفريق
البرهان اشار الى ان هذه الحرب فرضت عليهم
وانهم في حاله دفاع
هذا يعني انه مستمر في العمليات الحربيه
كما نرى لليوم الثامن لكن ايضا اشار الى
معاناه المواطنين من هذه الحرب ولا نرى
على الارض اي بادره لرفع هذه المعاناه
بوقف الحرب يعني يبدو انها خياره او
النقطه التي تريحه فقط انها حرب مفروضه
علينا نحن لم نختارها فسنمضي فيها حتى
النهايه لكن ماذا عن المدنيين لا شيء يحدث
انا اعتقد انه اذا الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
البرهان جدا في مساله ايقاف الحرب فعليه
ان لا يصرح بذلك للقنوات الفضائيه انما
عليه ان يبادر بالعمل بهذه المساله
والقضيه طيب هو قال بانه يقوم بواجبه
ومستعد لتحمل المسؤوليه كامله قال بان
الخاسر الاكبر في هذه الحرب هو الشعب
السوداني وندعو لحوار داخلي لحل الازمه ما
الذي يعنيه بحوار داخلي هنا هل يجب ان
تكون ايضا قوات الدعم السريع جزء من هذا
الحوار
هذه العباره تتحمل ذلك لكن يعني ما نراها
على الارض والتصريحات السابقه
للفريق البرهان تقول لا انه غير مستعد
للجلوس مع محمد حمدان نقلوه حميدتي وايضا
تحدث الان عن قضيه الدمج انه لا تراجع
عنها وهذه طبعا اصلا قضيه لا يمكن للتراجع
عنها ولا يمكن ان يوجد جيشين لكن الخلاف
كله هو في فتره وترتيبات
الدمج هذا ما لم يشير اليه ولا اعتقد انه
حتى هذه اللحظه ينوي التراجع عن مساله
الدمج الفوري التي يعني تتجاوز الاتفاق
السياسي الذي وقعوا عليه سابقا بالدمجه
التدريجي وكان الخلاف في ذلك الوقت هو حول
فتره الدمج طلبه القوات المسلحه بفتره
قصيره جدا بينما طالبت دعم السريع بفتره
طويله غير معقوله وغير منطقيه وتم الحوار
للوصول الى حل وسيط ولكن الحرب قضت على
هذه العمليه السياسيه كما اشارت الاستاذه
لينا هو قال بين قضيه الدمج هي سبب هجوم
الدعم السريع على على الجيش كيف يمكن
تفسير هذه النقطه السيد حمور
طبعا هناك اشكاليه في من بدا الهجوم يعني
الدعم السريع يزعم انه تم الهجوم عليه
القوات المسلحه تزعم انها تم الهجوم عليها
كل واحد يعني يرفع ذات الشعارات تقريبا
الدم السريع يقول انه يدافع عن نفسه الجيش
يقول انه يدافع عن نفسه الجيش يقول انه
يريد تسليم السلطه للمدنيين كما صرح الان
ايضا الفريق البرهان في المحادثه على
الجانب الاخر الدعم السريع ايضا يقول ذات
الكلام يعني كل واحد تقريبا يردد نفس
تصريحات الطرف الاخر قضيه الدمج نفسها
يعني اتفق عليها الجيش مع الدعم السريع مع
القوى السياسيه وهذه قضيه اول من طرحها هي
القوى السياسيه لم يكن لدى الجيش ولا لدى
الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان مشكله في
وجود جيشين لسنوات طويله جدا بل ان الجيش
السوداني لديه ضباط منتذبون داخل الدعم
السريع يقومون بالتدريب ويقومون بقياده
العمليات بل ان الفريق الاول عبد الفتاح
برهان قد عمل مع قوات الدعم السريع جنبا
بجنب في غرب البلاد لسنوات طويله هذه كانت
كان هذا يعني جيشين موجودين في السودان
ولم يكن لديهم اي مشكله في ذلك المشكله
اصبحت الان مع ترتيبات خروج العسكر من
المشهد السياسي يريد كل طرف ان يخرج الطرف
الاخر ليبقى هو هنا حدث تضارب المصالح
واصبحت قضيه الدمج التي طرحتها القوى
السياسيه والتي هي مساله صحيحه وسليمه
ووجود قوات الدعم السريعه اصلا من البدايه
التي انشائها الحركه الاسلاميه والنظام
البشير هو وجود خاطئ اصبحت هذه القضيه هي
المعضله الوحيده التي توقف عندها الاتفاق
الايطالي والعمليه السياسيه لان محمد
حمدان دقله حميتي يريد عمليه دمج طويله
جدا حتى لا يسلم سلاحه
لحليفه السابق عبد الفتاح البرهان بينما
يريد عبد الفتاح البرهان دمج فوري حتى
يجعل الحميدي من غير اي سلطه كذلك تحدث
البرهان عن تلقي الجيش بدايه في بيانه عن
ان البرهان تلقى عددا من الاتصالات من
رؤساء الدول لاجراء رعيها من السودان هل
تعتقد بان الجيش يستطيع تامين وضمان سلامه
هؤلاء المواطنين المواطنين الدول الاجانب
ورعياهم من السودان في ظل هذه الاشتباكات
واحتدام وتصاعد الموقف بين طرفي هذه
الازمه
اعتقد انه نحن نرى الان كيف يعني يبلي
الجيش في حمايه المدنيين في منازلهم
الصواريخ تسقط عليهم وهو يرى ان ذلك هو
حمايه ودفاع عن المواطنين لذلك لا انا لا
اعتقد ان هناك سلام وامانه الاجانب في
حاله الادلاء ستكون على الجيش السوداني
وحده ما لم تلتزم قوات الدعم السريع
بالهدنه وتلتزم ايضا بحمايه المواطنين
الاجانب في عمليه الاجلاء فلا اعتقد ان
الجيش سيكون كافيا من اجل هذه المساله
اذا لم يكن الجيش كافيه لهذه المساله فما
الذي سيضمن
سلمت هذه البعثات يؤمن هذه العمليه بشكل
كامل برايك السيد حمور ان ان يلتزم الدعم
السريع ايضا بذات التزامات الجيش وان
يساعد ايضا على عمليه الاجلاء لانه اذا لم
يحدث
اذا التزم بهذه المساله لانه اذا لم يلتزم
اي واحد من الطرفين سنكون امام اما فشل
عمليات الادلاء ويبقى الاجانب عالقون داخل
السودان او الحل الاخر الذي اشارت اليه
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه امس انها قد تتدخل
عسكريا من اجل المساعده على اتلاع رعاياها
ورعايا عجانب اخرين وهذه ستكون عمليه
خطيره جدا وقد تقود البلاد الى انزلاق لا
يحمل عقده وبالتالي هل هذا يعني بان
السودان يعني قد تدخل في دوامه التدخلات
الاجنبيه سواء بهذا التدخل الذي ذكرته او
حتى ايضا تدخل دول حدوديه مع السودان كما
ظهرت الانباء عن بعض الاشتباكات في الحدود
مع تشاد واثيوبي على سبيل المثال
وما حدث في السابق في الفشه مثلا نعم هناك
وهناك تلك الاخبار ايضا عن دعم دولي
واقليمي ياتي للطرفين وهو الامر الذي ايضا
يعني نفاه الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان بشكل
غريب جدا انه ان التقارير التي اتته ينبغي
ان تكون تقارير عسكريه واستخباراتيه موثقه
التي تقول ان هناك دعم جاء من احدى الدول
لقوات الدعم السريع فان ينفي تقاريره
الاستخباراتيه باتصال هاتفي من رئيس
الدوله ينفي فيها هذا الدعم هذه مساله
غريبه يعني ينبغي ان يكون راس الدوله على
ثقه بتقارير الاستخباراتيه اكثر من مكالمه
هاتفيه من رئيس دوله اخرى طيب
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على وجودك معي من
القاهره الكاتب الصحفي السوداني حمور زياد
اكد وزير الصحه السودانيه هيثم محمد ان
القطاع الطبي يواجه التحديات في امتداد
المستشفيات بالوقود مشيرا الى ان مخزن
الامدادات الطبيه الرئيسي تدمر بالكامل
توجد صعوبه في ايصال الامداد الامدادات
المركزيه ما تاثرت كانت هنالك مشكله في
الوقود لها تم التنسيق مع
وزاره الطاقه على ستار لايصال الامداد
الوقود بالنسبه لهم وطمنوهم في هذا الجانب
للاسف المركز الامداد الرئيسي مخزن
الامدادات الرئيس تي في ولايه جنوب دارفور
في نهايه نتعرض للاهلاك الكامل والحرق
الكامل
قال وزير الصحه السودانيه ان ثلث
المستشفيات المركزيه خارجه عن الخدمه بسبب
انعدام توفر الكوادر الطبيه وانقطاع
الكهرباء والمائي عنها
تلك المستشفيات تقريبا حاليا الخدمه وزي
ما هي مركزيه نقاط اشتباك في الغالب او
تاثرت بصوره مباشره النتيجه لضرب
السلاسل في الكهرباء والمويه وبرضو انها
غير امنه للكوادر الطبيه وللوص
للمرضى كذلك
السلام
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات